♪♪
Rebecca Ferguson:
As an actor, to walk onto a set
where you have depth and height
and shape and everything is authentic,
it just creates realism for us
to play around it.
♪♪
Hugh Howey:
The Silo is incredibly
cinematic.
It’s a new world told in a
completely new way.
This is as big as any feature
film, the number of sets we have
is seventy plus.
Morten Tyldum:
When we designed the Silo,
we decided to make all the
building blocks circular.
Morten Tyldum:
All the alleyways, the
stairways, everything has this round development to it.
The sets are incredibly moving.
Graham Yost:
They are the cathedral of the
whole story.
Rashida Jones:
Everything is magical.
It’s so detailed, it’s so
beautiful, the world is so well
realized.
(Cheering)
Gavin Bocquet:
Life in the Silo replicates a
lot of things we’re used to in our world,
Gavin Bocquet:
from living spaces to factories to
farms.
It’s a complete world built a
mile down into the earth.
♪♪
Hugh Howey:
The experience of watching the
world of the Silo come to life
absolutely blew me away.
Hugh Howey:
The scope of the Silo was even
bigger and more awe-inspiring than I imagined.
Rebecca Ferguson:
Everything is used.
Everything is recycled.
Rebecca Ferguson:
Whether they are phones or
watches or a little PEZ dispenser.
It’s so detailed, it’s so
stunning.
♪♪
It is just a gift to be able to
get lost in this
world in a way that feels
completely real.
♪♪
Morten Tyldum:
Creating the world of the Silo,
we wanted it to feel like
nothing you’ve seen anywhere
else.
♪♪